Kanye's new album is here the track that
calls out trifling Tristan Thompson
meanwhile it's another round of Drake
vs. push a t+ it's new music Friday and
it is lit hey this is the daily denne
denne and I am so freaking excited at
the end of the week because it is new
music Friday and we are starting off
with the biggie Kanye West dropped his
latest album yay
and he celebrated with a star-studded
listening party in wait for it Jackson
Hole Wyoming Thursday night Jonah Hill
and Chris Rock were among some of the
famous faces jamming out to the new
tracks and fresh off her meeting with
President Trump Kim Kardashian also flew
in to support her hubby and they got
that wyoming merch serving a sum Justin
Timberlake man of the woods vibes but no
surprise here
Kanye's latest songs are stacked with
candid references to what yay himself
refers to as a shaky ass year he raps
about everything including the fallout
from his controversial comments on
slavery and even bipolar disorder with
the album art which Kim told fans on
Twitter Kent Kanye shot on his iPhone on
the way to the listening party includes
the message
I hate being bipolar it's awesome but
it's the track all mine that got our
attention listeners Kanye name-checks
Khloe Kardashian's man that trifling
Tristan Thompson sometimes you get a bag
to boss something I call that ticket
Cory Gamble's find yourself up in the
food court you might have to enjoy your
samples already starts on Krista Mingo
we've almost what got just a single if
you don't bow like him a Kobe never
cheat that [ __ ] gonna leave you now
listen Kanye has been busy working on
two albums and this is just one of them
but like the life of Pablo and like the
cover art for yay Kanye is always
tweaking to the last second which is why
many folks are also asking if Kanye is
talking about Drake on the album now
listen
just before it Yai's Wyoming listening
party Pusha T buzz you guys know is not
a fan of Drake tweeted you got 100k
floating around for info can't no amount
of money create skeletons that don't
exist hashtag I'm upset
which
is the name of Drake's latest single
cuts the two songs off Kanye's album
which references that 100k including
yaks quote hundred grand will make your
best friends turn to ops I hear y'all
bringing my name up a notch guess I just
turned the cloud game up a notch
now not hard to connect the dots but
obviously open to interpretation I just
want to know what does it mean I
watching this whole Drake Pusha T
situation with my popcorn leg of course
the rap rumour mill has been running
full steam this week with Pusha T and
Drake's series of diss tracks that hit a
boiling point though and pushes shocking
allegations that Drake has a secret son
with adult film star Sophie Drew so
pushing even goes as far as to call
Drake a deadbeat on the track and Drake
has yet to say anything publicly about
the long-standing rumors but a source
tells et that Drake is actually the
opposite of a deadbeat dad and has been
supporting Sofie before and after her
pregnancy and adds Drake plans to take a
DNA test to determine whether or not he
is the father this is the best episode
of Maury Povich I have ever seen
but at least we're getting some good
music out of all this am i right now
speaking of let's get into some new
music stuff to help kick off your
weekend I'm so excited because gorillas
has a new song a nice summery pop if you
will and they've recruited a powerpuff
girl character for their music video for
humility starring Jack Black I know
there's a lot going on but it's awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
stay now
[Music]
right now that's oh we're we're ditching
[Music]
my crew guys just asked what is this
watching that I don't know but it's dope
and another music video making waves is
maroon 5 star studded visual for girls
like me get this it features 26 cameos
by some of the most fierce and diverse
women going on right now blink and you
might miss them
[Music]
I need
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
okay JLo dancing like no one's watching
you guys and finally my favorite pic of
the week Hayley kiyoko and Kalani is
what I need video is literally the queer
adventure that I'm gonna need six
seasons in a movie four well we'll have
to settle for this short film directed
by miss Haley herself
actually due for one
each other based on
and this video comes just in time for
Pride Month which kicked off today
shout out to my LGBTQ babies we've got a
lot three products or keep shining
bright and as a special treat we have a
behind-the-scenes exclusive with the
queer eye cast on the set of the video
for the season 2 theme song with Betty
Boop so enjoy I'll see you guys on
Monday good luck